my garage sale content
it is scary if you look carefully under
the hood how my garage sale content
leads to business for vaynermedia with
Fortune 500 companies
because the people that are consuming
the garage sale content are the children
of the executives who are making the
decisions to go with vaynermedia
content is never a bad thing
this portion is like with me so I think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you gotta go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]
and I'm going full time on my personal
brand thanks to you because last year
you told me to get onto Tick Tock and I
did and I hated it but I still hate it
but here I am
um so yeah personal finance yep
um and then I also have a podcast that I
co-host which is more in the like
navigating the workplace employee
advocacy that type of thing and I'm
trying to figure out how to put those
two things together but yeah Vancouver
Canada
um and now putting all my time and
energy into building good for you
awesome
you know Jeremy very well Jeff Jeffrey
hi I'm Jeffrey I can't say hi to Jeremy
good to see you brother how you been
awesome I loved it last time
I'm uh Jennifer Travis uh founder of
sealed concert and we're a virtual
reality Studio that produces virtual
reality experiences our mission is to
move people through the Magic versus
storytelling so we produce VR content
but we also have a technology that is a
motion pot that eliminates motion
sickness makes experience far more
immersive with scent and haptics and
primarily we're building a network of
different surrounding theaters in places
like museums tourist centers
um
a lot of B2B yeah makes sense awesome
pleasure so here to learn where are you
from I'm sorry uh L.A awesome so I'm
Kaya this is
um
women from all the way from puberty
through menopause so onset of Menses
interesting
so we're all about Buddhism
's like 80 of women have hormonal
imbalance balances I don't know what to
do they're giving Band-Aids like
I don't know if I should say it on
camera birth control things like that
and we want to give them like an actual
solution to their problem I love that
and we launched last year only direct to
Consumer subscription base and 100
self-funded wow it's awesome all Whole
Foods all Whole Foods I'm such a buyer
of this thesis changed my life
we got to get this out to ultimately I'm
disproportionately educated girlfriend
when it comes to Whole Foods I'm like
stunningly educated through osmosis I'm
well more prepared to help you now than
before so can't wait
good for you I think you really the
There's real upside in that other than
dtcc businesses are very hard
there's that part we'll talk about it
all right this whole side of the table
comes from Canada so we're going to
start with these folks in the middle who
are all one group here at Christine when
you guys introduce your thieves hi Gary
so I'm Christine lewington CEO and
founder of pip International uh this is
my daughter Shelby she's in charge of
marketing and this is Troy he's here for
high five so what we are is we're an AG
tech company and we extract the protein
out of yellow peas
sort of plant-based it's a clean
plant-based protein and we're going to
disrupt the industry because pea protein
tastes like [ __ ] and ours does not okay
so we have large companies I can't say
them on camera sure that are at the
table and how do I close them and how do
I raise the real money because I just
right now currently the guys are
commissioning our 30 million dollar
pilot facility and we're growing to the
200 million I bought the land everything
else is engineered and we're going big
because you can't go small makes sense
what tens of thousands yeah of course
just do a little bit and so I've
partnered with Hi-Fi who does things
that you I think are going to understand
the nft raising money so I'll hand it
over to Joy yeah quickly Jerry so I'm
Troy McDonald I'm the chairman CEO of
Hi-Fi Corp small U.S public company
private kind of a big company
we've built a Securities token offering
platform for clients very much like that
become an investor in our company as
well agritech Green Tech these things
are essential in humanity these these
private companies are looking to do
Capital raises and they're going to be
using our platform to use security token
offerings we have a new form of nft we
think we can take nfts from being most
of them being foolish to be very serious
and we actually have a new form of
security token offering completely
legally compliant in the US EU
investor now
uh for some types of operands for her
first offering yes it'll be a rick D50
but we'll also be doing reg eggs
understood
originally from Portugal living in
Canada for eight years now okay uh
influence a marketing agency
um 90 of our business is focused on
promoting gaming so we do
um dedicated videos Integrations
um in the most organic way possible
because I've been trying to do it on a
different way from those other platforms
um so we have been growing and I hit
kind of a threshold that I didn't know
where to go from here yep so I was
approached a few times for people to try
to acquire my company
um I didn't know what to do and then I
booked Matt Higgins on intro
um so I met Matt and he said like you're
crazy you're not going on that direction
you're going to learn how to build your
second tier
um of your company your management team
um that you don't have at the moment
um and you will grow your business
um and definitely you will need like
before these health
that's awesome that's very nice Matty
that's funny very cool where are you
based um Kingston and do you rep the
talent uh no you brought the brands yes
understood
cool
hang on let's rock and roll yeah so I um
have a podcast called it's time to lean
um with a co-host with a friend and that
is all about career
um you know like employee stuff but
that's really my personal brand which is
what I'm trying to trying to grow
um I'm I'm struggling I got a tick tock
I started you know doing all the like
repurposing the content and what I've
realized is that I'm more I'm an indoor
cat and social media is requiring me to
be an outdoor cat and I'm I'm like
struggling to figure out how to like
find my voice and why do you think to
grow really well let's let's let's break
it down because it's gonna matter for
everyone in the room
so introverted versus extroverted or
however you want to paint it
what let's go higher are you worried
about judgment
no no
[ __ ] okay
do you not have the ideas
because that's something that yeah
that's something I've been thinking a
lot more about and some of you consumed
my content for a long time even my own
team is hearing this for the first time
even Andrew films be like I've been
thinking a lot about the ideas I've come
to realize that I took for granted how
easy ideas are for me
we talked about this the other day for
Vayner and Sasha so this is what one of
the reasons I've started doing green
screen content again us making
assumptions that some of you are paying
close attention to me and others aren't
green screen have you seen this where I
take a headline from an article and then
I'm over it and I'm talking
what early on when Tick Tock was popping
something I said that I stopped talking
about that I'm going to start talking
more about is these platforms are now
helping people with training wheels like
when I first started YouTube it was like
camera post now with all the filters all
the features the music the this and that
these platforms are really trying to put
you in a position to be able to make the
content
the reason I like green screen a lot is
for a lot of people here no matter I
just listened almost every actually I'm
going to take this back everybody here
can speak
as a commenter on top of an article
within their field whether it's private
Equity or influencer marketing or food
or food or right or raising capital
almost everyone here like I Woke up had
an idea I think having a grudge might be
the great poison of our society I've
been thinking about this lately a lot
that if you actually are a human being
who is currently sitting with a grudge
that it's actually destroying you on an
everyday basis so I was interested in
that and normally the way I would do it
would be I would make you know again I
think all of you know like a garage I
branded post
White Title grudges are bad away we go
what I did instead with this new
behavior and I've got a point here for
everyone is I Googled articles about
grudges
scientific and things of that nature now
I'm a little scared because I know I
don't want to be a headline reader and
just take something that might be a
[ __ ] article you know so it's a
little challenging
but this is lightweight enough it's not
like I'm making a scientific claim or
you know like you know and so uh one
thing that I'm trying to tap into for
you is potentially the concept of is it
the ideas
indoor cat outdoor cat
speaks to putting out stuff most common
people are actually insecure about
judgment and whether it's physical
appearance do they really know imposter
syndrome things of that nature or just
really are at that place in their life
where two or three negative comments can
really throw them into a snowball if I
could sense that so then it might be
about the ideas
what I did and my whole thing is you
know I want to help other women who are
just like me you know what we I'm going
to jump in here what you've done is a
pro the only thing I do for a living for
the last 15 years is based off of what
I've done I've just gotten good at
making it more macro than a focus group
of one
it's the starting point
the only thing that you need to do in
those scenarios is not be fearful of
well wait a minute this is I
and understand how much of this is we
like even for these this is a meta
situation I'm answering your question
but trust me I'm throwing this at
everybody because there's different
versions of it for everyone so I think
not fearing
speaking from a place of one and
understanding how most things are
Universal and just changing some of the
words
of I to we may give you a starting point
let's keep talking this is why we have
this
is it a is are you are you lacking
patience for it us to get there no I
like I have all the time in the world
okay you know okay it's really for me
more Mission driven like I want to sort
of reach more women more moms people
that are you know I don't have a
financing well you just put everything
myself well you will
if it's an altruistic emotional point of
view it's completely based on patience
I wanted to reach everyone too start in
2009 very few people were watching
more people watch now how about the fact
that in 2022 I know that I haven't even
begun reaching how many people I want to
reach
yeah right it was only the last couple
years that I'm translating my content
into Portuguese now people in Brazil and
Portugal know who I am and they didn't
24 months ago so you know I I think a
lot of times if you're truly coming from
a selfless place
if you are and I think all of us come
from some version of selfish and
selfless place it's being a human being
then we really are talking about
patients because there is no hack I'm
not gonna be able to tell you to be like
well you know like for example green
screen why am I saying that because
green screen is over indexing that video
of me talking about grudges would have
gotten 400 000 views on Instagram from
my current situation the green screen
will get 1.7 million that's so that
that's a tactic that I love because one
it's working for people on the other
side two the algorithm is clearly seeing
that so it's helping with Organic reach
three it will help a lot of you make a
piece of content
in a way that maybe you couldn't
otherwise you have a thought you don't
know what to do in a one minute video
but if you Google an article green
screen it and then speak what you were
thinking about that subject matter now
you do have a piece of content I have a
30 person content team Andrew will tell
you that now is probably like wait a
minute Gary's basically now just doing
green screen he's doing it by ourselves
like are our job's in trouble like he
doesn't need us that's powerful that's
powerful and very powerful for a lot of
people here because I you know
everyone's like easy for you Gary you
have a team I'm like but I didn't have a
team for the first eight years of my
content creation
what about that part of the story
so what else well what else is so I have
this podcast and I'm I'm trying to
figure out how to because weave it in
yeah weave it in because all of my like
professional experience is a leadership
like HR employee you know I was a
manager you know so
um and I really most companies are like
shitty most managers are shitty and most
employees like don't know what their
rights are they don't know what they can
ask for or what you know how to go about
it and so I have this whole thing which
is really sort of skills bait like my
whole career which I love talking about
I love you know having so why are you
doing the podcast
because I love that and I have like so
much deep knowledge
um on on that but it's completely
different from that's okay the personal
finance stuff that's okay so let me give
you let me let me give you let me give
you an Insight so my garage sale content
it is scary if you look carefully under
the hood how my garage sale content
leads to business for Vayner media with
Fortune 500 companies
because the people that are consuming
the garage sale content are the children
of the executives who are making the
decisions to go with vaynermedia
content is never a bad thing
I often I just I wonder if if I think
like
if it takes away from nobody can't no no
no nobody no no nobody cares enough
that's ego
okay nobody's watching those two places
and be like I'm gonna take away from
this for like they don't give a [ __ ]
okay
that that is that is just pure ego like
nobody cares
nobody's by the way you just gave the
number one argument why everybody who
cares about me in business doesn't want
me to do 90 of the things I do
Gary you can't make a [ __ ] video
that's yelling into the screen about
receipts because the Jets won a football
game you're undermining your intellect
I'm like no I'm not
the end the we have a lot of classic
thoughts that were built on the old
media and distribution framework humans
are multiple things
You Can Be You Yes like who who
the only people that are telling you to
Niche down are people who sell Niche
courses and have never built anything
for real yeah that I like hate that [ __ ]
so don't do it correct I would tell you
to do more [ __ ] okay
okay like start a third podcast talking
about kites
I'm being dead serious I'm being I
believe the more you give the world to
attach with you there are people who are
attached to me because they're Jets fans
because they like garage sales because
they like wine because they like
business because they love modern
blockchain technology because they like
I give think about how I'm doing it
I mean it's everywhere and every like
it's complete like there is no logic to
it by old points of view it becomes an
energy cost game not a strategic game if
you don't have the energy to do both
that I respect
that becomes logical right we only have
so many resources financially or
emotionally but if you have the capacity
notice how quickly I said great when you
said I love it I didn't want to hear
anything else because that is an energy
driver not sucker people actually don't
understand this when I tell people to do
a piece of like you should do a Star
Trek uh podcast
they see it on service level the way I
say it which is like somebody else might
be a Star Trek fan and then they may
give you business what it really is in
Disguise is you love Star Trek so much
that that hour each week is giving you
energy for your other 60 hours my
obsession with the New York Jets and I'm
realizing right now because we've been
so bad for so long and now we're
actually having a decent season
I forgot because it's been so dreary I
forgot how that four hours on a Sunday
drives my entire week
so I think you need to be doing more
it's just that the content has to be
strong
and strategic across the board and
that's what 40s will teach out of like
the essence sock but that theory is not
true it's more that you just have to
make more content of the thing that you
want to monetize
got it it's not decreased the leadership
thing it's add more to the financial
thing okay
awesome I'm gonna keep doing what you
tell me to do there you go all right
Jeffrey by the way YouTube shorts
I'm repurposing to YouTube shortly but
when you like it's like
it's like hot mess well it's it's only
because it's early number two and it's
very big for all of you remember when
you title your YouTube shorts video
even if it's not directly obvious to
what the content you put out if you're
repurposing from tick tock title it for
search because YouTube is the second
biggest search engine in the world
right like so like you might make a
video that like lightly touches on taxes
but you might title the video how to
file your taxes in 2023 got it
because you're doing it for search all
right so you know I have ideas I just
started a campaign to start posting on
LinkedIn three times a week I want to
start a podcast where I interview the
filmmakers correct your content is a
very active voice but remember when the
target is a B2B decision maker that's
the sizzle the make sure back to like
jab jab jab right hook for every
filmmaker because that's cool
try to have somebody on the show once
every two or three times that is an
actual decision maker that you're trying
to reach
because you'll be able to use the
content from that episode as ads against
decision makers and she or he's going to
say something that is disproportionately
going to rev resonate with the people
like her or him
so where people get caught is they think
their thing is boring
and so they go for the cooler thing
right you thought properly I'm gonna do
a podcast who the [ __ ] cares about the
you know like the the light licensing
fee or the structure or some of the
hardware thing like that's boring what's
cool is the [ __ ] the movies right on
the flip side
you're doing it for marketing and you're
trying to shoot fish in a barrel of a
very small group of people I still
believe that one of the biggest things
B2B companies need to do is make their
content strictly for the CFO strictly
talking about why their thing saves
their company money
even if it's like like whatever that is
that's why I love HR all these Dopey
Dopey business people like disrespect HR
that's where all the money is if you
have retention and good culture all the
hidden gray of the money you're making
versus the black and white all the CFOs
pay attention to it's not even a fair
race it's a tortoise in the hair
nonetheless
um give that some thought okay right
okay sounds good and then the other
thing I was wondering that's just in
terms of calibrating the breadth of the
message so if I start writing posts I
want to create content I can get very
this is a strong but I get very suppose
and talk about what the minute
and this is again this is the sub you
know how we talk about subconscious bias
now in society like you don't realize
but you have these feelings and I'm
trying to get people to be okay with
that because we're just human beings we
grew up in our circumstances and the
quicker we realize we do have it and the
quicker we also don't judge people for
having it the quicker this world can get
nice
everything is and
it's unbelievable how deep the
subconscious bias of or is in business
if you're posting three times a week
and you know I want you to post four
times a day but if you're doing three
times a week
think about what you're asking
you're doing 12 posts a month and
there's nothing like like what because
of mine is am I going to seem very
consistent this goes back to the
ideology of like there's nobody's going
to read all 12 to begin with who are we
looking inconsistent to again what what
is really starting to and it's amazing
it's right off the bat on both these we
have a major major issue with over
believing Academia and under believing
reality
the concept of of who's consistent about
anything of course you're a human being
and you have your values and what have
you but like all of us as parents and
operators and human beings have to
adjust to reality at all times
we also should start championing
people's ability to change their mind
that is my greatest strength
new data new decisions
new information New Life situation new
observations you're not going to bother
anybody if you go high sizzle metaverse
and then come down hardcore nerdy you
know motion uh sickness technology
do you believe humans work that way
yeah like that's right I mean I'm to
your point one of the I almost think
that the reason I'm doing some of the
stuff I'm doing is to go to the extreme
I'm like a very well respected
businessman who's wildly not respected
by The Establishment because they see a
video of me buying a t-shirt for a
dollar and give zero [ __ ] because
there's no reason to all you're trying
to win on is relevance to as many people
as possible
the people that will eliminate you
because you're talking about multiple
things are the least interesting people
on earth
you're just trying to get people to
consider you and the way to get more
people to consider you is to touch on
more things
you're not you're not the encyclopedia
you're not BBC and even those things
we've seen evolve
right like even CNBC or like you know
like even like Wall Street Journal like
they if you look at the history of
Publications needs to expand for
relevance even though they started as
something very narrow it's the
inevitable
chess move
nobody's going to eliminate you because
you touched on two different things this
goes back to how I think it really works
I would challenge you to also add to
your content
what fly fishing taught me about
business
and make the whole first 17 sentences
about fly fishing because you love it or
darts or hockey or rock climbing or
surfing or chess
we need connection points when we're
going through that stream on LinkedIn
I'm more likely to stop if you're
talking about knock hockey than if you
are talking about the metaverse
cool you see where I'm going yeah do you
have a sense well before we run out of
here do you have a sense of which
communication style suits you best audio
video written word
I uh word or video I mean I don't mind
being on camera well then if that's the
case you should do video and then
transcribe have an intern or lowest cost
transcription right think about the
double benefit
you know if you're willing to do video
I mean I have a lot of I've written five
New York Times best-selling books and
have never written a sentence of it it's
all out of my mouth video
transcribed a book even the last book
because I did during covid literally
they like my team visited me at my
apartment I just talked we just filmed
it all
so and now you have much more content if
you film it that you can use in other
places so I would definitely lean into
the video and transcribe it to the
written work even if you directly are
doing an article speak it if you can
and let that be the written thing
because then even the video becomes
extra now all of a sudden you're at 12 a
week instead of 12 a month that's how
you get there
makes sense
cool yeah yeah well Gary thanks for
having us you've been a huge inspiration
to how we built the uh We've listened to
a tinier 4D so it's an honor to be here
humbled I'd love to give you just a bit
yeah
we launched last year I think the first
year was us really figuring out do we
have product Market fit we've hit that
we're at Mid six figure business right
now we're profitable we're reinvesting
every dollar in so we're barely
profitable for a customer acquisition no
we have not done any paid marketing no
people all Word of Mouth yeah yep so
that's kind of how we built the business
so we're doing about three to four
pieces of content social platform we
have a newsletter
for Instagram three or four per platform
per week day per day so how many what
total per day
oh um
12 to love love you
so pumped with you yeah
did everybody hear that yeah three times
a week
go ahead three times there we go my man
Progress
way better yes so it's been fun um you
know how like you know like I always
tell people in this one they're always
like Gary why is that I'm like you know
how you love we all love children
like children we universally all agree
like we love this seven-year-old we love
our children more yeah an influencer can
only love your product so much compared
to you
yeah so
start a podcast with
you want to talk about that for half a
sec because it's super important I think
you'll do well yeah
yeah so we're we started recording but
we haven't figured it out when you say
your own original cup just you guys on
the show yeah so I would do both in one
show
let me tell you how to figure it out
back to and versus or think in segments
I think the show should start with five
to seven minutes of you guys think about
Regis and Kelly like they like banter in
the morning like yes guess close the
show
so I think the way you should do it is
do six seven eight minutes of you guys
30 minutes with the guest six seven
minutes of you guys to close out maybe
that one has like a little segment or a
little game or hot take or you do
something with each other or like for
name Association or whatever
and then you're done
and then you have the post-production
for all of it
segments
and the way we're thinking about it so
YouTube for sure and I have a pot I've
been doing it for like two and a half
years weekly personal just passionate
buying that gives me energy I love that
thank you and we had some health
interviews and we saw it really works we
would now want to Double Down on YouTube
I guess for us like I don't know if I'm
being too conservative with our
marketing dollars we have not spent
anything like what do you think how do
you think we should probably can't get
more conservative than zero
all right I know I probably need some
help but Ed should we be spending where
should we be focusing on marketing I
mean doubling down on YouTube like that
makes sense when you guys have tell me a
good War story of a piece of organic
content that went viral go
I mean
one on Instagram it was like over a
million it was this like cocktail
mocktail that we did you should you
should take that video and run ads
against that against Target audiences
because the algorithm aka the human
beings everyone's like Mark Zuckerberg
China it's [ __ ] humans responding to
[ __ ] these platforms are very simple
they just want people to stay on it for
as long as possible so they can run ads
so they're not like like zucks isn't
pushing propaganda of like you loving VR
they're just [ __ ] math
and so so for you that mocktail should
be turned into an ad
correct it's giving people awareness to
your brand it might not be sales
oriented like you might run a thousand
dollars against it and get no sales and
you'll be like [ __ ] Gary but
meanwhile what I know is that you did
get sales you can't attribute it to it
so now people feel fond towards you
three weeks later they decide to buy it
they just go to the website because they
know who you are but you can't point to
the ad and you're like the ad didn't
work well the ads definitely going to
work because it already went viral
people are interested
I'm incredibly bullish on everybody here
running ads after it succeeded on
organic that's something that we haven't
lived in for a long time because it's
not how the platforms worked
so we have it way better than we did the
last 10 years we have to guess and run
money or run micro money see if it
worked and then poured fluid on it now
the algorithm does a better indicator if
it's going to work than even our micro
ad spends
so like to me if you're going to test
some stuff test it on the things that go
viral on your 12 a day
yes at some point
the holy grail for DTC businesses is to
find scalable math that works in CAC and
LTV the problem is most of them aren't
actually working profitably they're
using VC money to subsidize their
underwater CAC in LTV and then there's
eventually a funny game of chicken of
can you sell it before your math Runs
Out which is a [ __ ] challenging game
and one that I don't like to play
because it's like a fake business
see how the bee guy got going because he
knows that's what he sees every day
right that they're on the other side
trying to decide is this sustainable or
is this is a moment in time keep going
yeah
are you changing the copy we are good so
you'll take the same vid yeah so like
that's a quick hack that can really help
a lot of people here it's the same video
but the copy is different because the
audience is different on Tick Tock than
it is on LinkedIn than it is on Twitter
so something to think about just copy
changes or just slight little added
changes
yeah can matter yeah we've been doing
it too uh like the things that people
search on shorts and what are you seeing
ish
but I think yeah we're also Gathering
we're talking to Joe maybe making
content exclusively for YouTube look
even I have a repurposing model with
context but like there is no comparison
when you can make for a platform because
when I'm saying hey Tick Tock versus hey
everyone there's a noticeable difference
it's just you know I'm running a ton of
businesses so it's hard for me so I get
it and but it's real but the copy for
sure don't mail that in because it
doesn't take a lot of time you know like
there's certain things that you can mail
in AKA like you just don't have a time
or resource and energy but the copy
that's mundane like yes I know it's
easier to control C and control V but
like thinking like this person's on the
Instagram versus this person's on Tick
Tock matters
copy in the description and title if you
have it on the content yeah if you're in
the editing mode and you can change the
title like titles every thumbnail and
titles I mean I don't know if you saw
the viral video of Mr Beast like he
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
on the thumbnail now he's playing at the
single highest level but I understand
I'm spending millions of dollars on a
team that is doing the same thing in
theory
it's it's actually scary
how much the title and the thumbnail
Works which is why if you have a piece
of content keep this in mind that you
really like you just feel good about it
and you posted and didn't go retitle it
change the preview screen
change the copy go again three months
later six weeks later four weeks later
well I feel like we have a product that
I mean how much is it
it's 45 so we have a one month bundle
because you take it daily it's a daily
thing to support your hormones so it's
55 for one month and then you can get
three months it drops it down to 45 a
month and there's no one year
we don't have a one here why
no reason
what I like about one year is people
forget to unsubscribe and like like
things that nature and like you know
like it's definitely worth debating you
have longer tail you know to re-get
somebody to to get somebody to re-up at
month four versus the amount of people
that forget or are passive or neutral or
apathetic to it for one year is a lot of
money
how big is your drop-off after three
months the average right now for our
users is 4.8 months that they're with us
yeah I literally think if you go to 12
months instead of three months that that
number would be 9.7 months
yeah they're gonna be scared shitless
about if you're going to raise capital
expensive to re-engage
what are you doing with your lapsed
users I got something really good for
you
I got a real good one for you ready yes
yes I think that you should call
on speakerphone every single person
who's no longer subscribed and once was
for three months
I think you should videotape the
interaction of you saying thank you
not try to sell them to re-up but just
to build a relationship around the
content
and when you have successful conversions
you ask them if there will allow you to
put out the video of this successful
reconversion I think there's something
there there
well first of all the reason you should
do it is market research
I'm adding content creation and
reactivation of business
and I think you're small enough still
where you could just grind that yeah
yeah so calling literally calling and
saying I just want you to I just we just
want to thank you for ever being on our
service and just hopefully it brought
you some value and hope it sprung you
into action theoretically whether you
know we're obviously aware that you're
no longer using us but I hope it's
sprung you into a better you thank you
the most in so I used to do this quite a
bit for Wine Library the most fun part
of the phone call is when you're done
just doing love and good
and there's this awkward three second
pause because they're waiting for you to
give them an offer to reactivate but you
don't
try it even if you don't record it which
is probably the biggest friction of
everything I just told you I think the
market research you'll get to why people
unsubscribed like by the 19th call if
they all said the berries were the
problem you're like oh [ __ ] should we
even have berries like it like it's real
market research
Captain Hi-Fi all righty so I guess
we're in a little bit myself here before
we talk about raising money on the NXT
platform is we're B2B yeah but now I've
been forced to b2c a little bit because
consumers want so so dramatically so
talking to the big guys big
multinationals they're starting to
realize they need our food protein to
reformulate all the way through like all
of Korea's on board being able to see
what you know they're all wanting to
swap out soy protein with our pea
protein so how do I put the message
together and I'm not gonna say we don't
actually go on Tick Tock and stuff yet
but it's okay you know
um what's that I mean if you were if you
were B to B up to this point Tick Tock
is not the logical place to go yeah yeah
and so a little bit of LinkedIn being
cautious because we're small and big
guys are watching and wanting to stop me
so how would you sit and go okay what's
my marketing approach to get the
knowledge to to get the
the radical fans as you said behind it
so when we approach with Hi-Fi here and
do this nft launch
we get those investors
I'm sure Hi-Fi will tell you like the
conversion of you know
the what's really fascinating about the
crowdfunding the jobs act this whole
genre of the last 10 years is
it's great on paper in the way that a
lot of our ideologies are like our fans
are gonna but like you know I'm sure
they have plenty of case studies through
this like
the The Narrative is when people invest
even in micro levels they want a return
on their investment
you know there's like you know that's
very important
because you can get very caught in the
ideology of like people want pea protein
in the world for a better place when
they're writing a check
like they really do want it to return
even when you look at over-the-counter
stock in the popularity of Nike and
Starbucks and Tesla and Netflix there's
really fascinating psychology and like
how people invest they'll do it for
proxy they'll buy five shares feel good
that they love Puma but you know I think
a couple things one
the thing that's going to make them
convert is the financial story
not the ideological story of like why
soy is bad or this that the other thing
so that's very important because I've
watched every single Kickstarter every
single Indiegogo every single you know
modern nft fundraising thing like people
think this like they they think the
consumer
cares more about the story than they do
outside of the occasional like Robin
Hood like like where it's like a
memeification Reddit GameStop thing
which is much more deeply in the human
psychology of like [ __ ] the man than it
is I think give a [ __ ] that it was
GameStop
you know you've got to make sure it's
about the actual business story
so that's one like very like curveball
that like has to be grounded in
um
as far as so another thing real quick
that you said it's important
I have historically seen that people
scare are scared to put out too much
content because the big guys are going
to squash them
but but then not putting out the content
they don't get the awareness for the
thing they wanted to get done and one
thing that we all know about the big
guys is they're slow and they'd rather
emanate it anyway
right notice how many Giggles we just
got right right we just all know that
like it's I get it I think that's the
boogeyman I think what you need to do is
dismantle it on LinkedIn I really do I
because LinkedIn will service you twice
he'll service you for the the business
development deals because you're making
content that you know you're going to
Target I mean you could literally Target
the job so who are the what's the job
title description what's the what's the
job one holds in the big companies that
works with you what are they the cheap
what
Co
-op the fact that you can literally
Target the COS of the Fortune 500 cpg
companies with creative is [ __ ]
bananas
like LinkedIn didn't get caught up in
the issues that Facebook did so their
targeting is still remarkable
and so now if you know this video or
this article or this image is going to
be targeting the CEO well then you know
what you're going to say
which is then becomes the same game of
what you're going to say to the general
population of LinkedIn and YouTube
shorts is where I would go because of
the search capabilities on the
over-the-counter play that we're about
to get into yeah we have two Navigator
subscriptions to for this kind of
targeting that's right
that's right
but that is sales
the Navigator is spam email at scale I
want content like the reason it took
people a long time with LinkedIn was
LinkedIn obviously started as recruiting
and then when it got into marketing it
was lowest common denominator email
marketing let's just Spam the [ __ ] out
of all the people with the right titles
and get lucky right we all were
receiving end of this we all know what
I'm talking about we're ticked where
LinkedIn got cool and interesting was
and I started talking about it was three
four years ago when it started acting
like Facebook
right sales navigator to me is what I
told those two wonderful ladies to do
which is go very one-on-one like we
human people forget that humans are
animals this is back to like your tummy
and your gut humans were animals none of
us are confused by a bulk email we don't
even consume it
and the people that do like you probably
don't want to be doing business with if
they got tricked by a bulk email
right so so I think on the sales part
you go one-on-one I'd much rather go
one-on-one there
hey Don
saw you went to Duke because you looked
at their LinkedIn
go Devils anyway uh like the you know
like and then on the content you go
abroad
ask your question Gary what do you think
of the um
the state of the nft market isn't ready
for a headline
nfts a transition for publishness to
seriousness the contract is yeah I think
I think it I surely think it is 100 like
you know when I was saying all last year
99 of these things are going to zero
nobody wanted to hear me because they
wanted to make the quick buck
thank God I did that because I think it
would have really hurt my reputation I'd
be in a much weirder spot right now if
I'd impound that message thank God but
not thank God because that's like how
you do business you got to talk about it
I'm in this you know to I mean it's the
only reason I'm interested in nfts
if nft's Destiny was to be as big as the
collectible Market I wouldn't have spent
the last 18 months on it every hour
its Destiny is to be the
contracts of our entire Society
yeah I think the Market's ready for it
too so we want to tell that story we
think it's a Top Model story that has
a potential to go quite viral to tell
the story well but I don't think even if
it went viral even if you two are on
CNBC talking about like why you saw the
real power of nfts I don't think it
lends itself to people investing in the
company
this is where I started my convo with
you have to be very thoughtful on this
what I think your content needs to be is
why you have a good business
pound the living [ __ ] out of that
because I think you're right and it
might bring some general awareness it
may lead to some cool Business
Development opportunities yeah I want to
cross-pollinate the empty Market with
her you know what I mean I think I think
and it goes to and just because I said
that just because I don't think 47 000
people are ready now to write a thousand
dollar check because you've got that
article on CNBC and Business Insider
doesn't mean you shouldn't do it if all
of you leave with anything here it's
this Obsession of band versus ore like
you know how are we going to do just us
or the influencers why not both
like we really think there's these
decisions instead of just trying to push
and always
so I think there's some fruit there
potentially
but the news Cycles I mean also you're
like for all of us if we're thinking
about PR like I mean between the
recession and the American election like
I'm not even thinking about the rest of
this year
there's like nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
about anything
you know so I think keep that in mind
because there'd be a lot of noise in the
system and a lot of anxiety in the
system people don't give a [ __ ] about
anything when they're scared
what do you think about the story of uh
traditional bricks and mortar meeting
fintech so here you have a very
conventional person motor business your
pilot facilities 19 000 square feet
she's building a much bigger one right
yes she's coming into the fintech space
now we have a crossover we have
traditional manufacturing business with
Innovation coming into it which is the
innovative business itself yeah I think
I think that will be more challenging
okay is my intuition only because if you
really look under the hood the smart
money
already understands that our technology
is like talking about the internet like
when I first
didwinelibrary.com like people wanted to
write that article like liquor store has
website that was the story
that's like right the reason everyone's
giggling now is that's insane and I
think I think at some level
I I get where your energy is coming from
I just don't know if you're gonna get
buy-in from anything that's going to get
significant reach because I think most
of the business Publications that I've
been in this storm for the last two
years 18 months
the kind of cats out of the bag of like
this is a macro technology
I think your Spidey senses are right
from like normal people still haven't
grasped that but the the media like the
business media does understand that and
I'm not sure like
P Warehouse goes to blockchain is like
gonna like completely compel them but
again I don't want to be the beacon of
no I think it's worth a shot if you're
asking me the question I don't I don't
think it's this story the same way it
was 18 months ago I do think the
it's time for us to get serious about
what nfts are is definitely going to be
a universal story
my biggest passion though is for you to
pound the content to why you have a good
business
because if you if you're banking on
hi-fi which I know you but you but you
have to it's yes exactly he wouldn't be
here correct no but yes which is a
perfect answer of a real operator you
would really like this to be a financial
execution of money raising it's going to
be based on how much you can compel the
masses to think you've got something
good
and so like we so I have investors
obviously the table line of course devil
to dance with so if this was something
that we haven't tried it so we're going
to test it with the soft rays of five
million to 10 million whatever and we
have people at the table that are going
I totally get it right we're setting it
up for Success so you know I have the
500 million dollar players over here
they're coming in but then they want to
take your company of course this is so
much you're much more leverage this way
of course dip over here dip over here
the only way you're going to do that is
have mass amounts of people interested
in the business and that comes through
the content about the business about the
business like why it's a good business
yeah like why the cons and where you
bleed it into where you want it to is
the consumer trend is showing X
activating they blew up for Content the
fact that we had we had a blended news
release
and and
yes yes you see where I'm going it's
just so common for us to go it's always
and more
the cost of Entry is so low the back end
of it is so high
why wouldn't I mean why wouldn't we I'll
be way more focused on the business and
less on the content I already had like
no problem I'm thrilled and Joe's thing
yeah we're talking about building out
the infrastructure I should start like a
podcast and and start getting like those
um decision makers on the podcast so I
can get like more content so I can yeah
but in terms of the business yes
um so when I got to this threshold
um I feel that I'm a little alone in
those decisions of my own business makes
sense
um and I don't have that second tier of
management
um and I got scared of what like I mean
a big sea lots of sharks I'm a little
fish
um making myself out there and
successful out there because I've been
growing yes year after year
um so I got scared so the first question
would be how do you know when you should
sell or you should just keep investing
on yourself or building that second tier
team it's a very personal question first
of all there is no unlike a lot of the
questions here where I think there's a
real path
I always believe one should sell if they
want to sell let me break that down the
thought of ever selling any business
I've been involved in has been zero we
sold empathy wines because my partners
were of the life cycle where both of
them were on the precipice of getting
engaged and starting their next real
chapter of their lives and the dollars
associated with selling it were high and
it was going to change their lives but I
was like devastated like because like
you know because I just never even want
to have a company that I don't want to
have forever but if you are tired or
interested in something else or just
want to put the dollars in like but
selling out of fear because you think
something bad is going to happen is not
a good reason to sell that was pretty
much everything so when building like
because I'll tell you why the little
fish
can always succeed because there's not
enough sharks in the world to fill up
how big the sea is
it's a really big propaganda that sharks
have scared small fish into there's just
too much out there and if influencer
marketing there's unlimited Brands and
unlimited gaming influencers let alone
influencers for the rest of your
grandchildren's life
what are we talking about
right
um the toughest part with that is
um one of the biggest
advantages of working with Mentor has
been like we really care about our
clients and the fact that we are on the
side of the brand unless on the side of
the talent it's huge that gives us the
advantage and with always understanding
that we don't want to
change the type of content of the
content creator so we respect this
content so that's not what we are there
for but on the other side we are not a
talent agency that we are going to the
brand and say we have this town that can
promote your product I agree so the
biggest thing is is it goes with the
motto of my company is we connect brands
with audiences not with influencers so
way more important than finding I got an
influencer I understand the business
model very well yeah amazing so in terms
of like building that business should I
invest in preparing the people that are
already working with me and bringing
them up promoting them to always first
choice always first choice because when
you're homegrown you have context
when you're working with people for a
length of time you know a lot when
you're hiring from the outside you're
guessing
right but the question becomes do you
feel confident in anybody who's internal
or do they have the skills well the
question becomes do you feel confident
in them because skills are teachable
what about the will like or just the way
they work with you or who you think they
are as a human being how many employees
do you have
um
I I just readjusted like 18 probably 12.
good it's smart there's a lot going on
so of those 12. when we're talking like
this
who do you feel like when how many
people of those 12 do you feel like can
really actually grow
that work well that yeah that you think
about these 12 and you're like I could
see in four years him or her or him
actually being quite senior I would say
that they are all good people yep um
with with
um devoted to what they do if in three
years you have to go away for a year in
three years and you have to go away for
a year of those 12 people how many do
you think can grow into someone you feel
you could trust to keep an eye on the
house while you're gone for a year I
trust them I just don't know if they
have the skills but you already said
that I can get them the skills teach
them you can
I'll say I have like people inside that
well those people that you're thinking
about need to get an obnoxious amount of
your time
not your clients
the biggest mistake a company this size
does is they spend most of their energy
on getting new clients or with their
clients or scouring influencers when
they should be spending all their time
with the 12 people
when I think about this organization how
we got to fifteen hundred two thousand
people it was because of the time I
spent in 2011 to 2014 with a hundred of
them which 39 are still here
10 years later that's the organization
I also think that you hiring one person
that fills the gap of this insecurity
curiosity pondering that you're feeling
is very very very good and I would hire
it from something that is exactly like
you
meaning hire them from an organization
where they're the number two or the
number three which is probably even
better
that does similar work whether they
represent the talent or the brands
because I think just feeling your energy
you need to scratch that itch just that
one first person to be not having a
right hand is very discomforting for a
leader I always had that right I was I I
recruited my best friend Brandon to be
that with me and I had my cousin Bobby
and I had my dad and then when I started
this I had AJ right then we started
bringing people in
James when AJ was going through his
transition so one final question please
um we have like in terms of our content
what we have been producing in terms of
reels and antique talk has been focused
on the influencers or what influences
have been doing with us right uh but
that doesn't get us to them no the info
what the influencer is doing with you
run as ads on LinkedIn against CMOS in
Canada of Brands is what you should be
doing
did you get that yeah what the influence
the work the content that the
influencers do then you post by the way
you want a good one you green screening
video of an influencer doing work with
one of your Brands and speaking to why
this was well integrated or what brands
should be looking out for and then
posting that so you green screen it on
Instagram you post it on Instagram it's
gonna get 13 views you then take that
video and post it on LinkedIn and write
15 sentences or four or five and you
make it towards CMOS
or heads of media agencies
that will get you business
thank you and that's a wrap on this
session you guys if we want to have
chances to get pictures with Gary from
his office we got to get doing that now
so let's see thanks team